across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power grid the yellowstone super volcano
a financial collapse and protect
themselves when survival is the goal
it's into the spider hole go fast fast
fast fast
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
i'm gonna use
like this
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers who have devised
extensive plans
we could house you but i'm not sure we
could feed you for very long
gone to great lengths it's
going to get hot the temperature is
rising and made huge personal sacrifices
to ensure their very survival welcome to
my trap said the spider to fly
let's hit the fan let's go the experts
will assess their extreme preps and
decide if they have what it takes to
face armageddon
and to survive i am your worst nightmare
yeah we're all gonna die
this is doomsday preppers
[Music]
doug huffman is a retired defense
contractor living in northern california
but he hasn't quite given up his former
life for relaxing days spent on the golf
course is that not a little bunny you
could just love instead he devotes his
time to a new passion i used to kayak
and ballroom dance
quite a bit
i gave
all that up
most of my time right now is spent on
prepping i work seven days a week 10 to
14 hours a day i've spent between 30 and
40 thousand dollars in preparations
i'm preparing for the second worldwide
great depression
we're 15.2 trillion dollars in debt no
one's doing anything to address the
problems
we cannot continue to keep spending
money in this country
at some point this is all going to
collapse and there's going to be a
massive massive reset in the united
states and worldwide you're going to
have a shortage of food there's going to
be food lines again gas lines again
during the last great depression in the
1930s the unemployment rate rose above
20 percent homelessness was rife and
tens of thousands of americans relied on
soup kitchens to survive and doug
believes that our future holds much
worse in the first nine months
of
this type of economic collapse no food
no water and amazingly simple sanitation
without soap and water boom
disease everywhere rampant unstoppable
simulations have been done up to an 80
percent loss of our population
the government's not going to be able to
help you you are going to be on your own
and that is the reality
am i afraid of this economic apocalyptic
event not really bring it on
doug has been prepping much of his life
but recently he's expanded his
operations by turning his huge
california ranch into a prepper's
paradise
[Music]
well the whole purpose for me building
my self-reliant village is the if
something should happen you are only
going to survive in a communal
group believing that his first line of
defense against an economic collapse
will be keeping starvation at bay doug
has formulated a four-stage
post-apocalyptic food plan as well as
being able to hunt local game he is
breeding fish in his lake and building a
2 500 square foot greenhouse large
enough to provide 50 people with fresh
fruit and vegetables so this is my
greenhouse
that will supply me with
vegetables uh 12 months out of the year
he also raises a variety of farm animals
specially chosen for their prepping
advantages so when there's no grocery
stores this one rabbit will produce
approximately 50 pounds of rabbit meat a
year for me
rabbits are among the fastest
reproducing mammals on earth over a nine
month period just one female rabbit can
produce up to 800 babies grandbabies and
great grandbabies making them the
perfect renewable food source
i have them all named this is stir fry
uh we've got crock pot
right here all right we've got blackened
and we have cajun over here
yeah
gonna be surrounded in vegetables
[Music]
the rest of the food doug produces on
his ranch will be preserved and hidden
in three separate locations adding to
his already extensive supplies
so this is my root cellar this is
absolute essential
for all preppers
root cellars are controlled storage
environments buried under earth or in a
basement they were widely used to store
fruit and vegetables during the winter
months before refrigerators became
available and many preppers believe they
are the future it stores all of our
fresh produce
from the greenhouse
these sand boxes i put a layer of sand
in the bottom of a box i wet it my
carrots and my radishes they're layered
in here the high humidity of the wet
sand keeps doug's fresh vegetables from
shriveling while the cold temperatures
of the root cellar up to 40 degrees
cooler than outside combat mold and
bacteria
there's enough vegetables in here to
feed a family of four for the next two
weeks just in one box and this will
store for the next two or three months
a lot of these products in here are 25
30 years old all this juice it's six
years past its expiration date and as
good as the day that i bought it
fantastically sweet
how
25 years old
doug's 1 000 pounds of food stores will
last him well beyond a bad winter but if
his fear of a total economic collapse is
realized he knows hoards of supplies
will be useless unless he can defend
what's his
in terms of the violence
just ask yourself
what would you do
for food and water when you've had none
for three days
if people who are desperate
starving and thirsty know that you have
food and water they are gonna come and
try and take your food and water
supplies
and while civil unrest is a common
prepper concern doug has no intention of
investing in prepping staples like high
fences security cameras and motion
detectors designed to keep marauders out
his plan
is to draw them in
my plan for self-defense
it might be a little bit different i'm
not so concerned about holding the ranch
i'm perfectly willing to give it up the
most effective survival system is to
disappear
during the chaos and reappear
to just take back what you've lost
through years of training with the
special forces doug has become a master
in the art of camouflage
everything i have is gamowed i can
totally disappear in just minutes
you must master movement shape shine
silhouettes all the things that are
required to be effectively camouflaged
or disguised in any environment
camouflage began to be widely used by
the military in the early 20th century
because the development of military
aircraft made it important for soldiers
to remain hidden from enemy scouts
doug has 30 handmade camo suits designed
for every possible environment and
season you have to have the different
colors to fit your environment in
fall winter spring summer the grass has
changed the snow everything changes
appropriate camouflage is a difference
between life and death
doug hopes this unusual skill will allow
him to set the perfect trap for home
intruders
if someone takes his ranch doug plans to
fall back to one of several shelters
that he can live in temporarily
today he is putting the finishing
touches on a new build with the help of
his friend and fellow prepper brian so
i'm excited to show you my little
project i've been bragging to you about
this is a spider hole dude
yes
the whole big area just underground for
uh for me to live in
it's right in the middle of the roadway
too a spider hull is a combat term
widely used in the vietnam war it is a
camouflaged one-man foxhole about three
feet deep and seven feet long
doug plans to use them to hide in plain
sight for three to seven days at a time
this is where i would be
at the
end of the world
home sweet home
most important thing about this entire
project this lid uh has to be
camouflaged to match the surrounding
area we're just gonna add everything
that's around here all right we got to
make it look the same as everything so
all this dead grass that's through here
these little pieces of slate we want to
add after we get uh you know a good
layer of dirt on here and because doug
cannot predict which locations will be
safe from the chaos of a potential
economic collapse he's taken the proper
rule of a plan b
to a whole new level this is just one in
a network of spider holes built over
hundreds of miles
this is you know
my last resort but this is my guaranteed
survival system
i've got half a dozen of these strong
over the next 200 miles up to uh almost
9 000 feet how much will that hold oh
you could drive a jeep across it uh you
should like see your tractor over it
really
you want a tractor oh my god you got a
tractor
oh my god
what do you think
my plan is to retreat
ride it out and live to fight another
day that's what the spider hole is for
the survival is the goal it's into the
spider hole
and it's cozy in here
but doug has no intention of bunking
down in a spider hole for good
at night he will return to his ranch and
reclaim his property
i own the night it's been a way of life
for me for 25 years
i would return back at night
doing my recon
looking through the windows
getting my numbers
and it's a very very important
psychologically that i just start
dropping people within 24 hours
i'll just start taking you out day after
day after day
welcome to my traps of the spider to the
fly
and doug isn't only interested in one
man's survival he's training an entire
team of young preppers who can help him
rebuild the world from the ashes
doug huffman believes that our country's
massive debt will catapult americans
into the next great depression you had
better be prepared
because it is coming and the fact that
so many people put their head in the
sand that's a huge mistake based upon my
law of natural selection they're the
first ones to die and if an economic
collapse does ravage america doug thinks
there will only be two groups strong
enough to survive a complete societal
breakdown
you've got the absolute marauder killing
machines the scum and then you're gonna
have the small communities i'm one of
the good guys
it is my intention to be part of that uh
that good structure and wash out evil
but doug has no intention of being a
lone superhero instead he is creating
his own band of heroes
a team that can help him rebuild a safe
post-apocalyptic community on his
240-acre ranch twice a week i go teach a
youth group called the junior rangers
well my whole goal is is to train people
in an apocalyptic event and that's what
it's going to take is groups of people
that build communities and can defend
and protect that community
what's up guys
what's up guys
you guys are going nuts on the camel huh
that's beautiful guys with the lime
green grasses coming out that's like
right there
doug trains 32 junior rangers between
the ages of 10 and 19 in survival
foraging and camo techniques as well as
a variety of weapon and defense tactics
well it's fall so painting up these guns
with a little bit brighter greens the
green grass or the new grass is coming
out and it's always got a little
fluorescent green to it
and doug plans to make this young team
part of his post-apocalyptic plan
many will choose to join him on his
ranch if an economic collapse hits the
u.s
we've learned to prepare for an economic
breakdown
i'm stacking up on ammunition practicing
with my weapons daily you'll need a
source of water a source of food
shelter
my students myself friends and family
we're the ones who uh you know are going
to be the last people standing the good
people if hordes of armed and dangerous
marauders do fill the streets after an
economic collapse doug believes the
ability to escape and evade will be
critical
so today he's teaching the kids how to
escape quickly into a moving vehicle
should uh we have our second depression
that is going to hit this country i
believe in 2012 everybody's going to
escape and evade wear
to the mountains
they're coming up to our spot if you're
on the run
having the ability to jump into a
vehicle without stopping is critical so
boom we're gonna come flying through
here we're gonna extend that right arm
and just roll into the vehicle boom
we're in here
all right and notice i came up i'm
facing this direction boom
now i want to see that exit of the
vehicle facing me when you exit here we
go
stretch it out lower up front
there you go
that's it
doug can be a really cool guy really
laid back so let me get in here fire up
the truck and we'll get rocking and
rolling
but then when it comes to take care of
business it becomes kind of psycho
feet to the back feet to the back
okay good job guys
let's go
pop up on the stop of the truck go
yeah
that's my evasive rangers
that's survival folks doug is like all
the action figures you can think of all
wrapped up into one i thought doug was
crazy the first time i came here but i
definitely want to be like doug one day
so good job yeah psych okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
one two three
job
i'm tough on my students because i care
about them
i want my students to be the last people
standing always always prepared it's
going to happen anytime if some type of
apocalyptic event happens my group's
prepared we're going to maintain our
freedoms as a group and certainly in my
little community that i've built up and
that's what drives me
doug the experts practical preppers have
determined that your food storage and
camouflaged preps are impressive also
teaching your survival skills to others
will benefit you
yeah i think that's a that's an
excellent assessment of uh
my well-rounded skills however if you do
not have a sanitation plan for your
spider hole it will leave you vulnerable
to disease while you retreat underground
you simply dig
an additional hole in one of the corners
several feet deep and that that's good
for weeks in addition when you retreat
underground it is likely that your
supplies will be looted while unattended
i look at that as as a foolish answer
all right um i am your worst nightmare
uh maybe he doesn't understand that and
i will continue to work towards many of
uh their comments that
and we will address those
the rogers family live a seemingly
normal suburban life in alberta canada
but for 20 years they have been haunted
by a prophecy of disastrous times ahead
will their preps see them through an
uncertain future
[Music]
diane and greg rogers live on the cold
plains of alberta canada
they have a small daughter sarah
a cat named mandy
and a lizard named spencer
my husband and i have been married for
eight years now
[Music]
i am a stay-at-home mom hosea was
married to a pretty girl called gomer
and he loved her dearly my daughter is
coming up to her seventh birthday
it's the first aid sign perfect
i hope for a certain way of life for my
daughter
um and for us of course
but that remains to be seen
that's the future and i don't know what
it looks like that's why we prepare
[Music]
i'm passionate about prepping because
i'm
i'm haunted
when i was in college
i
had this dream
a disaster dream of some kind in that
it was something that happened
environmentally so what i want you to do
is be able to help me
get all of this organized okay it
continues to this day you worry too much
sometimes yeah i don't know if i worry
or i just i know
too many things i'm trying to escape
greg is getting our bags ready i'm
putting things away trying to get to a
colder place because
it's
going to get hot the temperature is
rising the dream happens all the time
for 20 years i haven't been able to get
away from it
diane is convinced her dream has a
connection to the real world
a warning for the future that cannot be
ignored
and studies suggest that she is not
alone
roughly a third of the population
believe that at some point their dreams
have predicted the future
it means to be prepared it tells me
it's something i need to pay attention
to my greatest fear is that something
catastrophic does happen
environmentally
and it sets off that chain reaction the
earth has
already suffered these kinds of problems
look at haiti look at japan and iceland
when the volcanic eruptions happened
diane and greg are determined to be
ready for anything mother nature can
throw at them so they spend up to 12
hours a week prepping for not one but
all potential disasters from climate
change and solar flares to devastating
earthquakes tsunamis and volcanic
eruptions we began to seriously start
talking about what would happen if
happened
if my little daughter always says daddy
how come you're always on the computer
well yeah because he is researching all
the time things that he thinks that we
need whether it be food whether it be
security greg's day job is as a granite
fabricator but at night and on the
weekends he is training as a security
tech a thief and even an amateur chemist
all in the service of being prepared
in an unpredictable situation you never
know
what skills you're going to need to pull
yourself out of that situation and
ensure your own safety and safety of
your family i'm learning how to steal a
car for the same reason i'm learning how
to pick a lock i'm learning to make gun
powder information is easy to carry
greg's latest do-it-yourself project is
a homemade charcoal gas mask homemade
gas masks to trap toxic vapors and
whatnot in the air have been around
since world war one
activated charcoal is readily available
in health food stores and when used this
way can act as a barrier by absorbing
harmful chemicals in the air i'm gonna
try and take the scissors and rough up
the inside a little bit
so that it really
gets into the walls of the mask now
having trapped the
activated charcoal in between the two
masks i'll just tape them up and
there you have it greg hopes this skill
will allow him to protect his family
against anything from tear gas to a
volcanic eruption someone might laugh at
me if they said why are you making gas
mask and paranoid no there's like
there's a thousand
reasons
that you could think of
to make a gas mask when i was a kid and
mount st helens blue in 1980 we were
right in the path of the ash cloud
having asthma i
i was affected by that
when mount st helens erupted it spewed
520 million tons of abrasive ash into
the atmosphere
most of the 57 people killed died of
asphyxiation due to ash inhalation
this gas mask would easily handle it
and then you
put it on
[Applause]
like so if you're dealing also
with uh
something in the air that would irritate
your eyes just get a kid's pair of swim
goggles that's good enough how's that
if diane's nightmare comes true and the
world suffers a cataclysmic event the
roger's immediate plan is not to bug out
but to stay put in their home and bug in
so despite a limited budget greg and
diane have spent three years stockpiling
enough food and water to survive for 12
post-apocalyptic months
if i go to the store to do my regular
groceries i might pick up a few little
extra things
that will go down
stairs into my storage area this is what
i was given for my birthday this year
close to 500 gallons of water hopefully
we can get several months if not a year
out of it we will have to ration i'm
sure
my priorities
are much different and that's one thing
with prepping is you don't focus on what
you want you focus on what your needs
will be grab that ant right underneath
here for the rogers prepping is a family
affair and they hide very little from
six-year-old sarah sarah knows that mom
and dad are putting food aside she knows
that we are giving up things so that
we're able
to get other things we might need for
the future
to prepare her for their worst case
scenario
greg and diane have a family prepping
talk every night before bed
we try to make it a game and have fun
with it shtf
when you hear mom and dad say that
now you might hear us say
it's the fan
it's serious
something terrible has happened you know
what you got to do
greg and diane would do anything to keep
their daughter safe in the apocalypse so
next they take a step into unfamiliar
prepping territory
a recent survey found that more than
half of americans fear that either an
earthquake a terrorist attack or a
financial collapse will occur within the
next 25 years
but diane and greg rogers are prepping
for an entirely different reason
their fear is based on a recurring
disaster dream that diane has had for 20
years which they believe foretells a
disastrous and apocalyptic future
whatever
or whatever natural disaster happened in
my dream all i knew was the sense of
urgency i had to get out i had to leave
the things that are happening in my
dream
may very well be real
so with thousands of dollars worth of
food and water stored and a young
daughter to protect greg and diane are
eager to take the next step in their
prepping plan what can you do for you
folks today
uh here to look at some handguns if
things come down to it where there is no
law
and
the only one who is going to defend you
is yourself
you better be prepared for that what i
really like is um
that nine millimeter the nine millimeter
it was a glock yeah so you're looking at
a glock are you this is a glock nine
millimeter
glock 17.
the glock handgun is standard issue in
over 65 of american police departments
and because of this widespread use many
preppers believe ammo and parts will be
easier to obtain in a crisis situation
butterfly your two thumbs because when
the slide comes back like that if your
thumb was there that's true it would
surgically gouge any part of your thumb
that had to be in the way
gotcha i'm not
a big gun enthusiast myself but i
realize the importance and it's another
tool in the tool chest sarah do you see
where you look to see about the
ammunition in there you've got to make
sure that the gun is empty whenever you
pick up a gun and you know what you do
if you ever see a gun
what do you do
you would call your parents yeah of
course you would call your mom or dad
right away and don't touch it huh sarah
knows there might come a time when mom
and dad need
to to use those weapons for things she's
okay with that and i would prefer that
she's comfortable around them
it's another step
towards finalizing and towards being
prepared of course you know what the bad
problem is
women will kick our butts all over the
range on on the sub-caliber guns and
they will out-shoot them in almost every
time so get ready to be embarrassed okay
yes of course they will again
you ready to go shooting range
sure let's go okay but in order to
protect themselves effectively greg and
diane need to be able to react quickly
and confidently against a potential
intruder in their home
to develop these skills gun experts
suggest practicing at a range at least
twice a week you're going to stay out
here right
you want to just walk just through the
window
[Music]
[Music]
i get bragging rights i get fragments
[Laughter]
she got the bullseye
right right
there
the latest government guidelines suggest
that being underground even in a
basement can provide extra protection
against anything from a tornado to a
nuclear blast so the rogers basement is
outfitted as a makeshift bunker along
with their food and water supplies they
have a propane stove
a medical and surgical kit
and even a porta body if
all of a sudden something happens and we
get the information that
oh my goodness something terrible has
happened our first reaction is to
go into our basement that is secure
the rogers wants sarah to be ready for a
bug into their basement at a moment's
notice and today they are running a full
practice drill with her for the first
time all we need to do is say shtf and
we know where we've got to go let's hit
the fan let's go
grab it
go
go fast we have packs prepared we call
it a dash kit with
food water medical supplies not only for
us but also for our animals we have dash
kits for them too gotcha baby gotcha
get in there
get in
go ahead quickly quickly round the
corner around the corner go go go go go
up on the bed because daddy's gonna come
down
okay
stay right up there
take a breath take a breath
okay that was good it was
under five minutes
okay
i want to try to cut that down i think
we can it's kind of like doing an
extended camping expedition if we need
to stay down there for an extended
period of time we have everything we
need down there ready for us
you okay
yeah it wasn't too much
a little scary um no it's just
the bags it was really heavy but you're
okay sitting up there right you feel
safe i think prepping has become such a
big movement because there is so much
more uncertainty
in the world than there ever used to be
we know so much more now
than we ever used to maybe it was easier
when we didn't know
the experts are impressed by your
extensive food preparations which will
keep you and your family sustained for a
year
but to prepare for the possibility that
your basement is taken over by a hostile
force we suggest that you have a second
supply in a different location which you
can access independently i agree with
that also you live in close proximity to
others which could be a disadvantage in
a disaster however you could turn this
to your advantage by establishing a
network within your community for
survival and disaster planning
there seems to be a bit of hesitation
among other people they just don't want
to think about it it's a learning
experience and and this is valuable
feedback so
uh i'm i'm glad we got it
ed and diana peten are modern day flower
children who prepare for the possibility
that economic turmoil may bring
desperate people to their front door
but will their plan to spend doomsday
underground impress the experts
the peace-loving hippie movement of the
1960s is still alive in 21st century
america pockets of holdovers can be
found all over the country even in the
middle of kansas
what's it all about
how big is it
that's where former school teacher ed
payton and his wife diana live and keep
the spirit of the 60s alive in a home
dedicated to peace
love
and prepping
i am preparing to survive and thrive
underground
we live in a decommissioned atlas e
missile site
somewhere west of topeka kansas
it's a very large underground hardened
structure keeps us very safe from lots
of things
ed originally chose his home because he
feared america would be attacked from
above
i first saw this site in 1982
ronald reagan was then president and it
seemed to me
that nuclear exchange was a real
possibility
these days he thinks there's another
ground level threat that's more likely
the economy is certainly in trouble
in some ways the economy has already
collapsed
and everybody thought the economy was
just going to bounce back it was just a
little recession well that hasn't
happened it's not happening
there's going to be desperation and
there's going to be potential violence
and those who can make adjustments to
the changes
in optimal ways will thrive
while many others are going to suffer
a false illusion
i spent seven years as a competitive
water skiing what a waste i would
willingly give up more frivolous
pursuits to be a prepper sometimes i
wish we had been more disciplined and
serious about this sooner ed believes
there is no time to lose and is prepping
as an economic doomsday is already
underway
we are at a critical moment
the banking institutions are troubled
the stock market is reflecting these
things
the politicians have no answers and we
are not finished with these trends he
and diana do take some comfort however
in the fact that their home was
specifically designed by the government
to survive the end of the world as we
know it
ed's base along with 26 others like it
was constructed in 1960 as a part of the
us military's atlas missile project
its previous inhabitant
a four megaton atomic weapon with 200
times the destructive power of the bomb
dropped over nagasaki here we are
getting on top of the missile bay area
here
we do give many tours there are a lot of
people interested in seeing our project
this entire area here is a very large
door weighs 400 ton oh my gosh and it
rolled back to the west
and then once that rolled back the
missile the 75-foot long rocket with a
nuclear warhead on top raised up out of
the bunker here and come to stand about
where the tower is
20 feet below this hatch a nuclear
missile rested in a horizontal launching
system appropriately called a coffin
launcher
it cost the government four million
dollars to build in 1960 but in the
early 80s ed bought the base as a
fixer-upper for around forty thousand
dollars
the paytons renovated their silos
command center and turned it into their
living space replacing launch codes with
lava lamps and advanced guidance systems
with cable tv
the main living area is connected to the
missile bay by a 120 foot long service
tunnel
so i'd say you could live down here if
something terrible happened on earth uh
this would be a good place to be if
chaotic things were happening above
ground yes if something did happen could
we come down here and live with you um
we would want to bring everyone in
but we would have to make wise choices i
couldn't answer that right now
if you were coming bring all the food
you could
the patents believe that as the economy
collapses food shortages will occur in
major cities then desperate and hungry
people will begin to migrate outwards
towards the bread basket of america
there's a lot of food grown here in
kansas as events unfold into the future
i think there will be many who think
about us here and there is a possibility
that
too many may want to come
unlike other preppers who plan to avoid
hordes of hungry refugees by retreating
to hidden bug-out locations the patents
plan to survive by closing their 20-inch
thick blast-proof front door and
permanently bugging in underground
the only sensible thing is to alter life
make preparations for the future that is
clearly coming
the payton household has special
features that make such a long-term
bug-in plan feasible they have 20 000
square feet of space
more than enough to hold their years
worth of food stores
they also have 18-inch walls built by
the military to withstand a direct
nuclear strike
in the 1960s five men worked here on a
schedule of 24 hours on 48 hours off to
mitigate the psychological strain of
life underground i didn't think i could
live underground because i really enjoy
light the sunlight the pains relieve the
stresses of subterranean living in their
own way this jacuzzi which ed and diana
installed in 2000 our hot tub here is
not just about surviving this is about
thriving and we love it
we don't get in the hot tub with suits
because
the laundry never rinses thoroughly
nobody seems to mind nobody seems to
mind
when ed and diana moved in this space
was cluttered with outdated
communications equipment and rusty
control panels the couple removed the
cold war hardware and turned this former
nerve center into a kitchen
i don't want to give up the good life
i want it to go on i want the american
dream to go on the way it's been
well maybe part of that is to reframe
what we think the american dream is
maybe it's not about having the little
house with a white picket fence
ed and diana's home is protected by an
eight-foot tall steel and barbed wire
gate built by the government to keep
curiosity seekers out
in all the years they have lived here
the gate has stood open
okay close again
but as ed fears an economic collapse
could unleash ground attacks in his
compound he has installed an automatic
control system
now with the touch of a button he can
close the compound off from outsiders
part of my role i am protector
of you
and of this place
and i like having the gate there
i think probably my most
nightmarish scenario is that there would
be a large group of maybe motorcycle
riding people with guns dozens of people
at the gate wanting in because they've
heard we had food they saw it on tv and
and so
that would be really a tragic scene and
uh may that never please never happen
next the patents have assembled the
ultimate and most unlikely team to live
underground with them for months or even
years
we're going to pass this stick around
and you can tell us who you are
but will the experts agree that they
have what it takes to survive
if ed's worst fears come true and
intruders breach the front gate they
enter his second ring of defense a field
of fire stretching for 100 yards between
the gate and ed's front door
keeping constant watch above this area
are seven surveillance cameras
ed recently upgraded his system so he
can control the cameras below ground
now he can watch every inch of the
property without ever having to come to
the surface
the security cameras are our eyes on the
outside world
today ed a product of the 1960s gets a
crash course on 21st century security
technology from sean a friend and
frequent house guest of the paytons
for a facility this size security can be
an issue for two people
edward and diana they can only do so
much together
so if we have a camera and a way to
monitor the premises it becomes much
easier for them to take appropriate
counter measures with this you'll be
able to zoom in
and you'll be able to actually identify
something as simple as a bag of
groceries
or a weapon basically what i'd like to
do with you guys is kind of have like a
dry run to where you would monitor me
entering the premises
okay
there he is he's got a long something
there
as it's a gun and he's aiming and
looking and these are not groceries he's
carrying you can still see him moving
yeah there he is there he is
coming through the gate
here he is right here at the door at the
door
if ed identifies that an intruder has
entered the compound with hostile intent
he is ready to set aside his desire for
peace and declare war
diana is absolutely committed to
non-violence
but i am not
weapons are death dealing devices that i
hope to to never use i don't show them
but i'm well trained in them and that's
all i would care to discuss about it
if ed and diana peyton's predictions
come to pass an economic catastrophe and
societal breakdown occur
they are aware that the two of them do
not possess all the skills they will
need to survive
so they have selected a group of people
to allow into their fortified bunker
we're going to pass this stick around
and you can tell us who you are
what preparations you may be making or
thinking of making and what you may
bring
to a time of change
that could be happening
[Music]
when preppers assemble survival teams
commonly sought after professions are
emergency room doctors mechanics and
professional soldiers
but for their team the patents have
selected a living food chef
an intuitive healer
and a spiritualist
there's a lot of
stories around 2012 that could be
really chaotic rick and i try to teach
people to get congruent and to get in
alignment with the changes that need to
happen on the planet
if difficult times do come and i think
that's most likely it's going to be so
important who you are around who you
have on the bus with you so to speak
[Music]
love is probably the essence of
preparation
and
love is the only engine of survival
i don't want to be
a voice
for somebody else's thoughts not anymore
not anymore
this isn't the compound that people buy
into and they have
guaranteed a room to be this is us
opening our home
to like-minded friends so the thought
that others might come to our home seems
quite unlikely to me and if they do i
don't think they would find that this is
really where they want to
stay
[Music]
ed the experts practical preppers agree
that your missile base home provides
protection from outside chaos
however while your subterranean home may
be safe you can still become vulnerable
if you do not properly monitor how
events are unfolding in the outside
world we recommend a ham radio which
will help you be aware of the situation
above ground
good advice additionally we recommend
you train consistently with whatever
firearms you store inside the silo and
consider investing in bulletproof vests
in case your home comes under siege i'll
choose my own way with that his
consciousness is at a different place
than ours
since national geographic was here
we had built
this set of doors
going into
the east side
of the missile bay area
and these doors
these doors are going to give us the
capacity to
lock down and more effectively control
this area
although economic turmoil in the
eurozone does not bode well
internationally the world bank has
predicted minor growth at about 2.5
percent for the year 2012. the
possibility of a global economic
collapse however cannot be completely
ruled out
[Music]
you